[Music]
right now business is booming for Lady
gaga sales up four albums have spiked
nearly 2000 percent since her Super Bowl
triumph and she is not going down
anytime soon
how does Gaga follow up the Super Bowl
with fishnets and sequined hot pants
that look kind of similar to her
halftime look but the question today is
does she have a new man was there a wild
and dangerous man with you after the
Super Bowl to celebrate he confirms Gaga
is dating talent agent Kristen Kirino
but last night she was solo sitting
front row and the Tommy xgg fashion show
and she wasn't the only star in
attendance
Fergie performed Cindy Crawford
genetically blessed kids were there and
so was Kris Jenner who gave ET on line
lauren zima an update on Kim
Kardashian's life four months after the
robbery how is Kim doing she's good
she's good she just testified is she
doing the process also a process putting
together the biggest fashion show to
ever hit la the Venice Beach runway was
900 feet long and took six days to build
for the look started six months before
inside his New York showroom GG's been
involved all the way with choosing the
buttons and choosing the colors
then only we were inside the private jet
as the 40 models flew across the country
and what to do on the plane ride but
sleep and practice go strut Bella Hadid
also walked the show but is she missing
her ex the weekend after he started at a
new romance with Selena Gomez Bella's
stepdad told us now there's a lot more
roads for her to go down you know but I
think she's rightfully concentrating on
her career right now
[Music]
you